French pastries and delicacies for
English afternoon tea and that's not the
only break with tradition here at the
William Curley boutique in London
customers sit at the bar to eat it's all
the idea of Scotsman William Curley he
worked in top restaurants in Britain and
France before opening his first dessert
bar in London in 2009
I like the idea to try to make things
more done in front of people so I guess
you touch them at the sushi bar kind of
concept but you can see things be made
in front of you I love how people get
close to what we do I think that's very
important and I get I guess remember the
deer sitting on a table hidden away we
wanted a bit more open more more a more
open space he's going to make his
signature chocolate cat oh the main
ingredients
lots of eggs sugar and of course
chocolate he begins with the base which
is a light sponge he whips up sugar and
egg whites till it forms stiff peaks
then he adds the egg yolks and finally
cocoa powder the mixture needs to go
into the oven quickly before it can be
flate and become heavy I think what I'm
trying to do in a certain extent and I'm
not the only one but there's a handful
of us in New York it is quite pioneering
if you want we're trying to bring French
patisserie
and to the UK market step number two is
humbly the seeds of a vanilla pod and
then the pod itself are added to cream
brought to the boil and then covered
with cling film to allow the aroma to
develop he been whisks egg yolks and
combines them with the hot cream the
mixture is then baked in the oven once
the cakes have cooled they will be
placed in the freezer
the third step is the chocolate coating
chocolate flakes are mixed into melted
couverture chocolate to give it a
crunchy texture on all the senses
absolutely you look at everything here
everything you smell everything you see
everything most importantly in case
everything the chocolate makes is then
spread onto plastic sheet molds and
allowed to dry at room temperature these
can be any shape it doesn't have to be a
cone
the final step is the mousse au chocolat
for the filling
with afternoon tea pastries they tend to
be smaller and they tend to be 2 or 3 if
that makes sense well i can t like the
concentrate on a patisserie i said to
say if that makes sense so when you have
it you don't you go through all the
stages if you like it the process
requests we touched on the flavor the
texture you know the beauty and the
dishes itself afternoon tea in england
normally features scones and clotted
cream along with fairy cakes and
miniature sandwiches they're not much
more than a mouthful so that guests
won't spill the filling tea is of course
a must
plus it's considered suitable for any
type of pastry but William curly wants
to shake up this tea tradition at his
bar guests can spend all day relaxing
relishing the French pastries
but I think in the UK you know we are
traditionally people would maybe have an
afternoon tea with 230 PhD scones and
finger sandwiches I think I said Batista
thought as time know that London had its
own high-end patisserie shop so I guess
from the influence you know from a
training in France and what I see in
France of the kinder brought that here
to London back in the kitchen the
chocolate cadeau are being assembled
with the mousse au chocolat the sponge
the frozen creme brulee and sultanas
soaked in rum
poor William this is the best bit to
garnish he adds a little goldleaf
presentation is after all everything
this patisserie is very popular at
William curly boutique and even enjoyed
outside of teatime